Wie ist die Frau Bauer?
32 Jahre.
32 Jahre?
Am 23. Mai 1992.
1992.
22 Richte?
92.
Tag.
23. Mai.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Bauer?
Ich habe mich jetzt lange nicht gemessen, ich glaube so 1,73 m.
Wie viel will denn Sie?
Ich will jetzt ca. 65 kg.
65 kg.
Frau Bauer, haben Sie allergen oder Unterträglichkeit?
Also bisher bekannt ist nichts, weiß ich nicht, normalerweise nicht.
Okay, gut.
Wie ist der Name Ihrer Hausarztin oder Ihres Hausarztes?
Das ist ...
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin 35 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren, könnten Sie mir bescheid geben?
Wir haben am 15. September 1989 geboren.
Ich schuldigen Sie, ich konnte nichts veröschten, könnten Sie wieder ...
Am 15. September 1989.
1989, danke schön.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin 1,70 m groß.
Wie viele wiegen Sie?
60 kg.
Und könnten Sie mir sagen, wie heißt Ihre Hausarztin oder Hausarzt?
Das ist die Frau Paul.
Frau Paul.
Und was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Büro als Spirationskauffrau.
Spirationskauffrau.
Okay, dann.
Was ist Ihre Hautbeschwerde, Frau Schmidt?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich wieder Bauchschmerzen habe,
wieder Blähungen habe und wieder durchfahre.
Was schmeißt du in Blähungen und durch?
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 5. Juli 1961.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr 1,70 m.
Wie viele wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 95 kg.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarztin oder Hausarztin?
Dr. Schäfer.
Herr Dr. Schäfer.
Frau Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin der, der von der Frau Paul.
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 11. Juni 1968.
11. Juni 1968.
Okay.
Brauchst du wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 m.
Wie viele wiegen Sie so seit?
79 kg.
Okay. Vielen Dank.
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
42.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. Januar 1982.
1. Januar 1982.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,72 m.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ungefähr 75 kg.
Herr Müller, was fühlt es dir so?
Wie kann die Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 24 Stunden schon seit gestern
Übelkeit erbrechen.
Und auch ein bisschen durchverleerlich.
Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. Januar 1942.
1. Januar 1982.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,72 m.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ungefähr 75 kg.
75 kg.
Herr Müller.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
60 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. März 1965.
Wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege so 70 kg.
70 kg.
Und ich bin 1,64 m.
1,64 m.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 22. August 1951.
1951.
Okay.
Herr Stein, wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ich wiege momentan ca. 95 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
75 kg.
Alles klar.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausärztin?
Dr. Schmidt.
Herr Schmidt oder Frau Schmidt?
Frau Schmidt.
Danke schön.
Frau Ort, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin genau
68 Jahre alt.
68.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Am 25. Mai 1900.
Wie bitte?
1957, ja.
Ja genau, 1957.
Danke.
9,97 m.
Nein, nicht 900, 1957.
1947.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
Ja, wie schwer sind Sie?
98 kg.
Was für Sie so uns, Frau Ort?
Ich bekomme nicht gut Luft.
Und ich kann nicht mehr laufen.
Was meine Sie?
Ich bekomme nicht gut Luft.
Und ich kann nicht laufen.
Okay, Frau Lindemann, vielen Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 1866.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,60 m groß.
Und wiege zur Zeit 68 kg.
Z. Okay.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Noch bin ich 34.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18. Mai 1990.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,86 m.
Wie viel wegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ich bin wiegt 98 kg.
98 kg.
Und was ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Frau Lüthals, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. April 1979.
79.
In dieser Monat gibt es Ihre Geburtstatemier.
Genau.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,72 m.
Wie ist Ihre aktuelle Gewicht?
Ich war heute Morgen auf der Waage.
85 kg.
Okay.
Jetzt können wir Ihre Beschwerden anfangen.